des cerceaux des ballons et des figures
spectaculaires bienvenue sur cette
compétition interdépartemental de gm au
rendez vous était organisée cette année
par le club d'elancourt maurepas sur
deux jours les 17 et 18 novembre au
palais des sports d'el en cours
il ya quatre départements pas forcément
tous les clubs donc c'est vraiment
mélanger il ya 4
lieu en ile-de-france qui fondent et
interdépartementale et il ya à peu près
3 125 gymnastes
il ya tous les âges de dix ans jusqu'à
plus de 18 ans je sais pas quel âge à la
dernière et c'est par catégorie alors il
ya catégories d'âge et catégories de
niveau parmi les 320 gymnastes présents
certains se sont entraînés pendant
plusieurs mois pour être prêts à le jour
j avec beaucoup d'entraînement parce
qu'il va forcément il faut s'entraîner
ça prend du temps
j'ai bien détaillé tout le monde
enchaînement partie par partie
et trois cours par semaine et ça fait
six heures par semaine de croire que
c'est quand même beaucoup pour réaliser
des performances de haut niveau les 19
compétiteurs du club d'elancourt
maurepas ont voulu profiter de
l'avantagé d'évoluer à domicile a
l'habitude de s'entraîner sur les
praticables à voir c'est un peu plus
simple le club dillon courbot repas est
finalement ressorti de la compétition
avec sept podiums dont quatre premières
places la structure pourrait de nouveau
accueillir la compétition l'année
prochaine